c'est le huitième vaccins passée au
peigne fin par l' agence européenne des
médicaments
ce mardi l'organisme a annoncé le début
d'un examen continu du vaccin chinois
sinovac pour évaluer son efficacité et
sa sécurité
si les résultats sont concluants il
pourrait arriver prochainement sur le
marché européen
la décision du comité des médicaments à
usage humain de commencer l'examen
continue est basée sur les résultats
préliminaires des études de laboratoire
et des études cliniques
l'ema évaluera la conformité du vaccin
que 8,19 inactivé avec les normes
européennes habituel d'efficacité de
sécurité et de qualité
l'évaluation d'une éventuelle demande
devrait prendre moins de temps que
d'habitude en raison du travail effectué
pendant la révision continue l'agencé
européenne des médicaments qui explique
aussi le procédé utilisé pour développer
ce vaccin contre le coc u19 celui dit du
virus inactivé le vaccin contient le
strass qu'ovide 2 qui a été inactivé et
ne peut pas causer la maladie
le vaccin commis 19 inactivé contient
également un adjuvant une substance qui
aide à renforcer la réponse immunitaire
au vaccin
sinovac a déjà été autorisé au chili au
brésil en ukraine ou encore en turquie
mais son efficacité a été remise en
question par la chine elle même suite à
la publication d'une étude brésilienne
étude selon laquelle elle ne dépasserait
pas 50,4 % les autorités sanitaires ont
donc étudié la possibilité d'utiliser
deux vaccins différents entre la
première et la deuxième injection
le 16 avril dernier une étude chilienne
accorder davantage de crédits à sinovac
estimant son efficacité à 67% pour
prévenir les cas symptomatique à 80%
contre les décès et 85 % dans le cas des
hospitalisations pour forme grave de co
vide
à titre de comparaison astrazeneca est
autorisé dans 65 pays alors que son
concurrent chinois n'est pour le moment
présent que dans 22 pays
cet examen continu de l' agence
européenne
devrait donc éclairer les zones d'ombré
autour de sinovac et de son efficacité